this is front line covered critical care
alliance
yeah
um the
fl
c
had their
paypal account suspended or cancelled or
whatever so what we have here is a group
of doctors
who hold a heterodox position now it's
actually one held by thousands of
doctors
but the problem is they have been
unsuccessful the big they that runs
youtube and associated properties has
been unsuccessful at silencing the fl c
and the reason they have been
unsuccessful is that these are highly
credible doctors with a tremendous
amount of on-the-ground experience
tremendous number of lives saved because
they have innovated new standards of
care for covid right so people want to
listen to what the not everyone but many
of us want to listen to what the fl
triple c has to say it's a relevant
clinical experience and they are meeting
success right in their clinical
experience in their clinical experience
demonstrable success and so the point is
oh well the attack that drives them into
obscurity um by using the terms of
service of the various platforms has
been unsuccessful the propaganda
campaign
that has been used to blur the
distinction between them and another
group associated with trump that has a
similar sounding name all of these
things have been ineffective and so what
are we going to do now well
we're going to allow them to speak but
not be supported by people who want to
hear what they have to say right where
did you say what the screen showed
because it was it was very small and
there are some people listening and not
watching which was especially small for
them
uh the ones who are just listening but
yeah so the screen shows a tweet in
which the fl triple c reveals that
paypal has suspended their account this
is not the first time this has happened
right for example wikileaks has faced
the same
this is the first time it's happened to
fl triple c i believe that is correct
but the basic point is there's some
force that wants to create an artificial
consensus and it likes to use the
lightest hand possible right if it can
drive you into obscurity with the terms
of service of the various platforms on
which you might choose to talk to people
it will certainly do that but if it has
to get in the way of your livelihood
very directly by interfering with
people's ability to use a credit card to
support you or to use paypal or any of
these things it will do it and those
aren't the ultimate layers there are
layers even below that that we will see
i mean we saw
uh various things pulled uh
the um
for example amazon web services that
didn't allow certain
alternatives to twitter
uh to exist um on their service there's
lots of places to
when are we during the election okay um
so things were uh
during the last presidential people were
thrown off of twitter they showed up on
another platform and then that platform
suddenly found it couldn't use amazon
web services as a host and so the point
is there are lots of choke points right
we haven't seen them all yet some of
them we've seen very occasionally and
some of them we see regularly like this
terms of service nonsense
here's another one that i found
absolutely jaw-dropping
um can you put up the paper the wayback
machine
that i sent you zach
here we have a paper unfortunately i'm
going to be unable to read it on the
screen that tiny but this is a paper by
jessica rose
and peter mccullough these are both
doctors i can read the title from here
um yeah go ahead a report on myocarditis
adverse events in the u.s vaccine
adverse offense reporting system vares
in association with covet-19 injectable
biological products
so this is a peer-reviewed paper that
jessica and peter
are had published and
elsevier the publisher has now withdrawn
this paper it hasn't withdrawn it
formally what it's done is put up a
notice in its place zach could you put
up the notice
temporary removal and just then yeah a
temporary removal and then can you read
the line the publisher regrets that the
article
has been temporarily removed a
replacement will appear
as soon as possible i really that's tiny
from here i can't i can't yeah the last
thing the last thing it says is that
when the paper is put back up it will
contain a notice about why it was
removed uh if it is not fully reinstated
so
this is very exotic here we have two
yeah highly which are always it was
published in current problems in
cardiology current problems in cardio
just so people who aren't academics or
or doctors no elsevier is one of if not
the largest academic publisher oh it's
better than that
okay but that's but it's also true what
i just said it's absolutely true uh it
is also i believe the oldest academic
publisher this is by its own account
right you know who they claim what is
elsevier
elsevier what is by its own account
elsevier by its own account is the
oldest academic publishing house in
existence and they proudly proclaim
themselves galileo's publisher now if
one
um
wow yes if one
delves deep enough you find out that
that's a little bit of a dubious claim
that elsevier is the name of something
that did not have a continuous existence
but nonetheless for a publisher that
wishes to you know to wave galileo
mantle of publishing galileo right um
that is a remarkable failure so i've
never seen anything like that uh that
removal i've nev and you know i spend
i spend a fair bit of my time looking at
academic papers on on elsevier's site
and other places i've never seen
anything like that and it reveals the
whole bankruptcy of this entire uh i
don't even want to call it a discipline
it's many disciplines participating in
the same failure
what exactly were
were rose and mccullough supposed to do
with their finding regarding myocarditis
other than publish it where other
cardiologists
could scrutinize it and challenge it
they did exactly what you're supposed to
do i've seen the paper it's excellent
this is a very good paper does that make
it right no but what do you want to do
to find out if it's right you want to
put it in front of peers out in public
and let that discussion happen
and now it's gone and it's not just you
know if they hadn't gotten it published
it might exist on a pre-print server
right but presumably since it was
published it's now simply not available
at all except via
wayback machines right and so all of
this is to say
that we have a consensus
about
the safety of the vaccines about the
ineffectiveness of early out of patent
treatments but that consensus is built
out of intense coercion
right we've had people
have their livelihoods interrupted we
have people's reputations threatened we
have people's peer-reviewed papers
removed from the web the point is if
you're looking at that consensus and
saying can that many doctors be wrong
you have to ask yourself the question
well which doctors am i not hearing from
and why how many doctors are afraid to
say what they know how many doctors are
being threatened with the loss of their
jobs reputations careers everything this
consensus is not a consensus right and
the problem is that a lot of frankly
high quality thinkers who don't happen
to have experience in
science aren't spotting this and they're
simply looking at the number of voices
all saying the same thing and saying
it's gotta be right
[Music]